hello everyone i welcome you all to
simply learn in today's session we'll
deep dive into node.js framework and
we'll discuss each and everything that
you need to master this framework we'll
start this topic by discussing what is
node.js and how you can install node.js
in your laptop or desktop and we'll end
with the interviews questions that are
frequently asked in the node.js
interviews so watch the video till the
end if you haven't already subscribed to
our channel please do so so that you
never miss an update welcome to this
video by simply learn in today's session
we're gonna learn all about node.js so
without further ado let's begin and look
at what's in store for us first up we'll
understand what exactly node.js is then
we understand the necessity of node.js
then we'll learn about some of the parts
of node.js node.js express framework
node.js use cases and finally we'll look
at some of the industry trends so what
exactly is node.js now consider a
scenario where a user interacts with the
web application the user only interacts
with the front end of the application
but there's a lot of work that goes
behind the scenes
now in a web application there's a front
end a server and a database the front
end is developed using javascript and
frameworks like angular and react while
the server is built on java php or
node.js and the backend database that
stores the data usually consists of
mysql or mongodb so node.js is an open
source cross-platform javascript runtime
environment for running server-side
applications it is used to develop io
intensive web applications like video
streaming sites single page applications
online chatting applications and other
web applications it is used by large
established companies and newly minted
startups node.js was developed by ryan
dal in 2009 and at the same time of this
session its latest version is v13.3.0
now that we know what node.js is let's
go ahead and look at why it was so
prevalent in the field of web
development
here are a few points first up node.js
is extremely fast being built on google
chrome's v8 javascript engine its
library is extremely fast in code
execution note package manager has
around 50 000 bundles for developers so
whatever functionality is required for
an application can be easily imported
from npm all apis of node.js library are
asynchronous that is non-blocking it
means a node.js based server never waits
for an api to return data node.js
dramatically reduces the processing time
while uploading video and audio files
it is also an open source platform and
is easy for beginners for web
development the above reasons more than
justified the popularity of node.js
platform and why it is being adopted by
large number of organizations and
businesses today so now moving on let's
familiarize ourselves with the parts of
node.js node.js consists of several
components now let's look at them one by
one first up we have modules now modules
are like javascript libraries which are
used in a node.js application to include
a set of functions now we can use
required function with the parenthesis
to include a module in a nodejs
application node.js application has many
modules to provide basic functionality
needed for a web application some of
them could be http util fs url query
string stream and zlip next up we have
console the console module provides a
simple debugging console that is similar
to the javascript console mechanism
provided by web browsers now the console
can print messages to std out that
prints standard output messages and sed
to print the error messages the next
component is cluster now nodejs is built
upon the concept of single threading
programming a single instance of node.js
runs in a single thread to take
advantage of multi-core systems the user
will sometimes want to launch a cluster
of node.js processes to handle the load
a cluster can be added to an application
in this way here's a small code for you
the next component is global now global
objects in node.js are available in all
modules now these objects are functions
modules strings etc some node.js global
objects are mentioned in the table you
have dir name that is the directory name
file name exports module and require the
next component is error handling now
node.js applications experience four
types of errors we have the standard
javascript errors system errors user
specific errors and assertion errors now
errors in node.js are handled through
exceptions now for example let's handle
an error that would occur when we divide
a number by 0. now this error would
crash the nodejs application and so we
should handle this error here's a small
code for you next up we have streaming a
stream is an abstract interface for
working with streaming data in node.js
streams are objects that let you read
data or write data continuously there
are four types of streams first one is
irreadable these are these types of
streams from which data can be read
writable these are the types of streams
to which data can be written
duplex these are both readable and
writable streams
lastly we have transform these streams
can manipulate the data while it is
being read or written moving on to the
next component buffer the javascript
language has no mechanism for reading or
manipulating streams of binary data
buffer is a module that allows handling
streams that contain only binary data an
empty buffer of length 10 can be created
by this method next up we have domain
domains provide a way to handle
different io operations as a single
group domain module intercepts errors
that remain unhandled there are two
types of methods that are used for
intercepting these errors firstly we
have internal binding in this case the
error emitter executes its code inside
the error method next up is the external
binding now here the error emitter is
explicitly added to a domain via its add
method the next component is the dns the
dns module enables name resolution for
example it is used to look up the ip
addresses of host names dns module is
used to connect to a dns server and
perform name resolution by using the
method dns.resolve the dns module is
also used for performing name resolution
without a network communication by using
the method dns.lookup the next component
is the debugger node.js includes an
out-of-process debugging utility
accessible via a v8 inspector and
built-in debugging client this node.js
debugger is not feature packed but
supports simple inspection of code it
can be used in the terminal by using the
inspect keyword before the name of the
javascript file in order to inspect a
file say myscript.js you can use the
following method
now that we are familiar with all the
major parts of node.js let's go ahead
and learn about the node.js express
framework
express is a flexible node.js web
application framework that provides a
wide set of features to develop both web
and mobile applications you can assume
express as a layer built on top of the
nodejs that helps manage the server and
the routes now let's have a quick look
at some of the core features of express
framework it is used to design single
page multi-page and hybrid web
applications it allows setting up of
middleware to respond to http requests
it defines a routing table that is used
to perform different actions based on
the http method and url it also allows
dynamic rendering of html pages based on
passing arguments to templates now
moving on let's take a quick example of
a simple hello world program now this is
developed using express framework to
gain a better understanding all right
first up we have the wear express now
this is used to import express framework
into our node.js application now the
app.get method is a callback function
with parameters request and response the
request object represents the http
request and has properties for the
request query string parameters body
http headers etc the response object
represents the http response that an
express app sends when it gets an http
request now the application will listen
to the defined port which in this case
is eight zero eight one and variables
host and port will contain the address
and the port respectively lastly we have
the console.log which is used to show
the address and port in the command
prompt so this is what the command
prompt would look like and finally the
output is displayed on the web browser
having learned about the express
framework now let's move on and look at
the node.js use cases
now it is no doubt that node stands out
for its speed and intensive data
exchange so top industry leaders like
nasa paypal netflix among others
incorporate node.js first up we have
netflix the world's leading internet
television network with over 117 million
users is one of the top companies that
trusted their services to node.js the
reasons why the company chose to use
node.js for application scalability and
data intensive application now you must
be wondering what application
scalability is this basically the
potential of an application to grow in
time being able to efficiently handle
more and more requests per minute and
data intensive application allows
millions of people to stream netflix
simultaneously next up is walmart now
walmart is the world's largest company
by revenue with around 514 billion us
dollars according to the fortune global
500 list in 2019. again the reasons why
the company chose node.js were
asynchronous io and efficient handling
of concurrent requests now asynchronous
i o which is a form of input output
processing allows other processing to
continue before the transmission has
finished nodejs is able to efficiently
handle concurrent requests with the use
of thread pool and event queues uber
uber is an american multinational
ride-hailing company offering services
that include peer-to-peer ride sharing
ride service hailing and food delivery
the reasons why the company chose
node.js were asynchronous io quick
iterations and active open source
community as mentioned earlier
asynchronous io permits other processing
to continue before the transmission has
finished now quick iterations now
node.js is continually being updated and
added new features that help in further
improvement in the performance of web
servers and finally active open source
community resolves many problems that an
organization may face in a particular
scenario next up we have nasa now nasa
is an independent agency of the united
states federal government responsible
for the civilian space program as well
as aeronautics and aerospace research
the reasons why the company chose
node.js were reduced access times
handling of data intensive tasks and the
fact that the servers are active 24 7.
now nasa has lots and lots of data and
using node.js has really helped them in
reducing the access times it is also
continuously handling and working with
large streams of data node.js is highly
stable which helps in keeping the server
active 24 7. next up we have paypal now
paypal is an american company operating
a worldwide online payment system that
supports online money transfers as
opposed to traditional methods like
checks and money orders the reasons why
the company chose to use node.js or the
fact that node.js has extremely fast
build times it allows tasks to be
carried out with fewer lines of code
when compared to other server
technologies like java and php and
nodejs being data intensive efficiently
handles a large amount of data next up
is medium medium is a popular online
publishing platform developed by evan
williams and launched in august 2012.
the main reasons why the company chose
to use node.js were a data-driven
applications now these applications are
ideal for being interfaced with node.js
servers b to run a b tests now a b
testing is essentially an experiment
where two or more variants of a page are
shown to users at random and statistical
analysis is used to determine which
variation performs better lastly node.js
server maintenance is simpler than its
counterparts moving on to the last topic
of this session industry trends now
node.js developers are in demand across
the globe since many companies are
adopting javascript libraries according
to forbes it is one of the top 10 most
in demand jobs according to note source
the total number of node.js downloads
increased by 40
in the last one year the use of nodejs
in production has increased dramatically
since its release in 2010. with early
adopters such as linkedin paypal and
netflix among others node.js has seen an
exponential increase in its use in web
development the popularity of node.js is
also accounted to javascript now since
javascript is the most popular language
as evident from a survey conducted by
stack overflow in 2019 many developers
can start working on node.js library
with not much of a learning curve
node.js developers are being offered
better salary options than other web
technology developers according to pay
scale the average salary of a node.js
developer in india is around 6 lakhs 13
000 rupees per year the average salary
of a node.js developer across the united
states is around 105 000 us dollars per
year in this video we'll help you
install node.js on your windows system
so without further ado let's begin the
first thing you need to do is download
node.js from their official website
so go ahead and type
download
node.js
navigate to their official website
and here
you can see the 64-bit version so go
ahead and download that once the
download is done go ahead and run the
downloaded node.js installer
accept the license agreement keep the
default settings as it is
and then say install
so with that we finished the
installation process
once node has been successfully
installed the next crucial step is
verification now this process ensures
that node has been properly installed
to do so we first open the command
prompt and then type in a few commands
to verify the successful installation we
type in this command
node hyphen v now this command returns
the version and if it returns the
version it means it has been
successfully installed
so here we go it returns the latest
version
now the final step is to update the node
package manager
now this npm is bundled with nodejs
which consists of all the repositories
and packages required for development
purposes so to do that type in the
command
npm
install
npm
hyphen hyphen
global now that we're done with the
installation of node let's go ahead and
implement a small program for that we
make use of a text editor in our case
we've installed vs code so go ahead and
download vs code once you're done with
the installation this is what vs code
looks like so go ahead and click on file
and create a new file it's going to be a
simple program where you're going to
print a hello world message on the web
browser to do that we make use of http
modules so node comes with built-in http
modules to transfer data across it
so for that we make use of a require
method we create a variable first say
var
http
equals required
and just say http within single quotes
now the http module can create an http
server that listens to the server ports
and gives a response back to the client
to do that we make use of the create
server method so let's go ahead and type
the code
say http
dot create
server and internally it consists of a
function
now the parameters to this function are
request and response now the response is
basically used to write to the client so
we say response dot write and here we
type in the message say hello world
welcome
to this tutorial
once you're done with that you end the
response
so the server listens to a port number
to display the message by default it
listens to the port number 8080. so we
keep that as it is and we end it save
your file
say
demo.js maybe demo1.js and say save now
to run the program you have to open the
command prompt so open your command
prompt
and mention the path to your file so in
our case it's our desktop on the desktop
so cd
desktop and now to run it say node
demo1 dot js now you navigate to your
browser
and say localhost 8080 and here we go
our message is successfully displayed
today we're going to jump into node.js
and the architecture around node.js
so why would you want to get involved
with working with node.js well there's
actually a lot of great reasons a lot of
the top web applications that you are
working on today are built with nodejs
and the architecture beneath it allows
you to not only just build those web
applications but to be able to build
in-class applications and by end class
we're meaning microservice driven
applications or applications that are
running on uh your phone on your desktop
on your tablets they can all be built
with node.js
and there are huge advantages around
working with node.js
one of the biggest ones being the huge
community around node.js and node.js is
just one of those standard solutions
that you use for building out your core
architecture when you're building out an
application and there's just a lot of
people out there that are using it
so let's jump into web applications and
how it'd be of benefit to you with your
web solutions
so
with node.js you have the client side
and the server side and the client side
has the solutions that allow you to have
hooks into the client side put together
very easily
so behind the scenes of the client you
have service and technology and
connections to your database so if
you're building out your solutions with
node.js it makes it very easy to be able
to architect the entire solution from
top to bottom for your entire
environment whether you're building that
locally on a test server whether you're
building for a traditional data center
or if you're working in the cloud
so on the client you're going to be
using technology such as react.js and
angular in the server you're going to be
using node.js php and java
and then the database itself is going to
be something like mysql or mongodb and
actually the number of databases that
can be supported with node.js is
increasing all the time
so when you're working with writing your
code in angular or react.js you can even
use view that's actually a great one
working with node.js you have this
client-side framework that provides the
hook into the web browser whether it's a
mobile web browser or a desktop web
browser the server is then responsible
for taking those requests that are
coming from the browser and
interpreting them and so on the server
you're going to run node.js you're going
to run it alongside with php and java
php if you're not familiar is a really
great way to get started with uh writing
uh web applications that run on the
server java is just a really solid
traditional
application language for building out
web apps
and then the server itself is going to
be responsible for those client
interactions with backend services
connecting with apis and reinforcing
your security model now can you do all
of that in the client yes you can do a
lot of that in the client particularly
with the frameworks from angular and vue
they are really flexible you can do some
great things there but one of the things
you want to be looking at when you're
working with building your web
application is really three key things
one is security the second is being able
to scale your solutions and the third is
speed and responsiveness and what i have
found through my own architecture is
that if i balance out between clients
and server the load and the structuring
of how you actually build those
solutions it really helps
create a very seamless solution to your
customer
and then at the back of all of this you
have your database and my sequel a
mongodb of two popular databases but you
can also use node.js to connect to many
of the clouds databases that are running
on aws azure google cloud ibm other
services they all have connectors in
fire node.js into their databases
so let's talk about the node.js
architecture and understand why it's so
good
so to begin with node.js has what's
called a single threaded event loop
architecture and this allows you to be
able to handle
many many concurrent clients at the same
time it's just a very flexible way of
being able to scale up your support for
many clients
and then in addition to that we have the
javascript event based model along with
the javascript callback mechanism that
allows you to have this standard
approach to being able to connect with
and talk and discuss interactions
between the client and the server
it's good to have these kind of
standards where you're not using
something that's unique to a specific
framework or a specific technology this
just makes it so it's a more accessible
for everybody
so if we look at the actual node.js
server itself everything centers it
around the the concept of the event loop
and the event loop has a a an event
queue an operation completed and fire
requests threaded pull and then it'll
actually do the actual computation or
the file system interaction
all of this interconnects in a nice
seamless loop the great thing again with
node.js is that it's not new technology
it's been around for almost a decade
it's very very well tried out many of
the largest websites out there are
running node.js
so let's now dig into each of the parts
of the node.js architecture so let's
talk about requests
so the way that the request works is
that you have
your framework
such as angular
on the client and that will then send a
request to the website and there's many
ways that those requests can happen
through web workers through forms and
through other interactions
but at some point a request is sent to
the server
and so these requests can be for data
they can be for deleting data they can
be for updating data they can be for
interacting with services as mentioned
before but the goal is to have some kind
of request now once that request
actually hits the server and then we
start actually getting into the cueing
and threading process that centers
around the event loop and this is where
node.js really excels because it's able
to use that single threaded model to be
able to manage from just even a few
requests to tens of millions of requests
so it receives the actual request and
starts the event queue and this is where
a single threading process starts is by
queuing everything up appropriately
and then it then maintains the thread
within a pool so you have the queueing
process as one action and then you have
a threaded pool which manages those
threads as well
and then we have an event loop which you
know goes through actually receives and
processes those requests
and then finally what we're doing is
we're actually going to be interacting
with a system and that could be a
database it could be a cloud system it
could be an api file system but we're
interacting with something that's
outside of the node.js server so the
node.js server itself is doing some
actions on the server but then it's also
interact with things outside of its own
server environment
and so let's talk a little bit about
that workflow
so requests come in they go into the
event queue and they get spiraled
through the event loop and then we have
a non-blocking operators which are going
to be doing the input output polling
such as kq epoll and other services and
from there we're also going to be then
interacting with the threaded pool and
we're using the blocking operations to
manage that threaded pull
and that threaded pool is going to now
then go outside of the server and
interact with something beyond the
server so whether that is a database or
file system or api or microservice these
are things that can be interacted with
and so let's go through some of these
advantages that we have here so so i'm a
fan of working with node.js so i have
lots of advantages so the one the big
ones are right off the bat is the
ability to be able to handle multiple
client requests
quickly and easily this really is
important as we move into our digital
ecosystems and we start scaling up
solutions you'll find that as you build
successful apps the demand for those
apps will grow exponentially and what
that means is you need to be able to
have a solution that can interact with
requests quickly and easily
there's no need to create multiple
threads because of the event loop again
this is another thing that's really
critical when it comes to building out
solutions you want to be able to have a
solution that can scale massively at the
flip of a switch now particularly as we
start working on building out
cloud-based solutions
nodejs also utilizes a really low
resources and memory again when it may
seem like a small thing when you have a
solution and it's using just a maybe a
smaller amount of memory but if that
solution keeps adding to that memory
usage you then restricted for how big
that application can grow so the less
resources and memory a solution is using
the faster and higher it can grow in
scale and we're going to be going
through working with node.js and node
package manager today
so let's go through why you'd want to
sit through this tutorial and what
you're going to learn well first of all
we're going to talk about the node.js
modules and wide node jsb and modulus
architecture is of benefit and how you
can leverage that
then we're going to talk about what node
package manager is and how you can use
it with the modular architecture
why you'd want to use npm
how we actually go through and do the
installation of npm it's actually pretty
easy so you should be able to jump on
that really quickly
then we'll actually go ahead and
actually go through the details of what
it takes to create a package.json file
with npm
and finally we'll do a live demo we'll
actually step through using terminal
window to actually interact and build
out an npm package
so let's get started
let's talk about node.js modules first
and understand the architecture and the
modular structure behind node.js so that
you understand why it's so important to
have npm
so let's talk a little bit about modules
so modules in node.js they provide the
functionality that you can use for your
applications
this actual architecture of nodejs is
built in such a way that it allows you
to be able to create solutions and
extensions very quickly and easily
so it has many modules that require
additional functionality for different
applications
that you can customize and modify to
meet your needs
so some of the
most popular modules that you have for
node.js include express uh js which uh
is uh becoming an ever more popular uh
back-end architecture for building out
solutions
we have uh react.js
which is from facebook
we have node daemon an open source
solution
and each of these modules are very big
solutions themselves but you can also
create smaller modules
that would be of benefit to the types of
applications you're creating so you can
kind of think of modules in a sense as
microservices so that you can actually
build out solutions that you can
re-share over and over not quite the
same but
similar kind of thought process for
actually how you interact with them
so let's go through what npm is
so npm itself stands for the node
package manager
no
great shakes there as the name says it's
responsible for all the packages and
modules that are bundled within node.js
so the node packet manager itself really
has two key functionalities and the
first is that reply it is a central
repository for all packages and modules
which you can then search through um
online you can go to search.nodejs.org
and you can find all of the packages and
modules that are out there
the second is that it's also a command
line or terminal
line utility that allows you to install
those packages so you can actually go
through and you can see the version
management and dependencies within those
packages and you actually can control
the packages themselves
so why would you use npm
so npm is really useful for being able
to extend the project you're working on
so when you're building out a project
one of the concepts i like to use is the
concept of lego bricks um big fan of
lego and
what's great about lego bricks is that
they're all individually by themselves
very small very specific functionality
but if you actually get a whole
collection of lego bricks together you
can build like crazy cool things so
think of when you're working with the
node package manager itself is that each
of those individual pieces that you're
working with
each of those individual packages are
their own lego bricks and by themselves
you can then edit and update and
maintain that piece um separately from
the whole environment as long as your
inputs and outputs they have really the
piece where you snap the lego in or when
you connect lego to something else
are interactive and open and well
documented then you can actually then
use those modules effectively throughout
your project
so you can actually then be able to do
that you can do version control on your
codes and dependencies you can do
testing very easily
and then once you actually get to the
point where you go yes i want to release
um a new module you can do that
effectively using npm and it will
actually go through and do the actual
deployment for you
so let's go through the npm installation
so the actual package manager itself is
included with the installation of
node.js so if you've installed and
you're running node.js
locally then you've already installed
the package manager uh but you can also
access it through command line or
terminal window um on your your data
server or in your server farm or in via
the cloud
uh if you haven't now downloaded node.js
here's the website where you can go down
to install it and there's windows and
mac versions of that
code as well with the installers which
allow you to get up and going very
quickly
uh you want to be able to run the
installer and accept all the default
settings uh just um you know to begin
with you want to kind of have the
standard set up so that you are most
familiar with the normal settings before
you start getting to the point where
you're a master and you're tweaking
things
um there is a way that you can open up
the command window or the terminal
window
and once you've actually installed
nodejs um to verify that it's actually
installed you can write the command node
dash dash version and i'll show them
pull out the version of node.js that you
have installed and then you'll be able
to see that you've got it actually up
and running
and then you can also do the same thing
for npm we can do apm dash dash version
and it actually will then show you which
version of the node package manager you
have running so you can actually take it
full advantage of that program and
verify that it's actually up and running
so let's actually look inside of a
package so packages themselves are
actually just json files
if you're new to this space json file is
a structured file format that's based on
javascript it's a very xml like format
for being able to
write instructions for the actual
package itself and so the json file
forms that you know really kind of the
the heart of each package you create
it has all of the metadata that you'd
have about a particular object
and then it provides a root directly to
any of the applications or modules
that the package may be referencing
in addition and it has any other
additional
information about the project that such
as dependencies and other files that
need to be included so here we have is
an example of a package that would be
created
using npm json script
and you can actually take this package
file as it is right here
and use the command npm in it and it'll
actually run this package and so you
would actually have a demo application
up and running really quickly
uh you can then go ahead if you want to
you can edit any of these parameters so
like for instance if you wanted to
change the description or the version uh
or what is the the main index script
that would be written you know these are
all things that you can edit very
quickly and easily you can just use text
editor to make any of these edits
and so we have the different metadata
that can be updated
and so this is where we go in and do a
full demo of working with npm
so what we're going to do now is we're
actually going to go ahead and actually
run a demo of using npm and to do that
i've got three windows in front of me
right now so i have this window here
which is my terminal window
where i'll be doing all my instructions
and then i also have a
folder which shows where i'll be putting
all of the files and then finally i'll
actually have a text editor in this case
i'm using vs code because it's free
but you can use any text editor you like
to be able to go in and show what the
code that's been created
by npm in the json file so you can
actually see what it looks like
and then we'll modify it a little bit so
first thing we want to do is we want to
go ahead
and create a
new project folder so i'm going to go in
i'm just going to move into
i'm going to do
change directory i'm going to
the project folder and we'll see down
here that we have an empty project
folder um but for this one i'm actually
going to go ahead and i'm going to
create a new directory in this one and
i'm going to call this one
simply learn
and there we are we've created a new
simplyland folder
and we are going to
move into the simplyland
folder and so we're now in the simply
land folder uh there's nothing in that
right now um so the first thing we want
to do is we want to take uh go ahead and
initialize this folder as a project
folder for working with mpm now to do
this you will have to already installed
npm if you have no js npm comes with it
and if you want to see whether or not
you have npm installed so you can just
do npm
version
and that will actually tell you what the
version of npm you have installed is it
also verifies that npm is installed so
i've gone ahead and i've been able to
validate that i have npm installed so
what i'm now going to go ahead and do is
i'm going to initialize this folder so
to do that you just do npm init and
you'll see that the path is that we're
already in the simplyland folder and
then when you do that
it's going to ask you some questions so
what is the package name we're going to
go with the defaults for right now and i
can show you how we can edit those in a
little bit
we're going to go with just say yes to
all of these just by hitting return
and you'll see here that we're going to
create a new folder called a
package.json folder this is the
instructions that we have in the folder
do we want to go ahead and create this
we want to and it's going to go ahead
and do that and we can see now in our
folder here that we actually have
package.json so we go ahead and open
this up with
vs code
here we are we can actually see what all
of the information is we can go ahead
and we can actually go and update
this metadata if we want to i'm going to
leave it as is for right now because i
want to show you a couple of other
things so a lot of times when you're
actually working
with npm and the reason why you're using
npm is that you want to take advantage
of packages that are freely available in
the open source community that are
supported by node.js and one of those is
a package called express and express is
a lightweight framework for building out
web applications similar concept
to angular or react js
i like using it and it's also a great
way to be able to show how we can
install this using npm so to install
this
you just start with the command npm and
then you type install
and then we type the name of the package
and we hit
enter
and it goes ahead
and what you'll actually see
is a couple of things one is we have a
dependency in our package above
we also have
so this is in our json package that is
now dependency is written in there
we can also go in and under our node
modules we actually see that we have
we scroll down we should see express
there it is express
now if we decide that we don't want to
use um express we can actually just come
in and we can write command npm
uninstall
i can type
express
oops i did a typo there so let's try
that again npm
uninstall
express
and a couple of things going to happen
one is
in our json file the dependency for the
express file has now been removed
and we can also see that under our node
modules there are no extensions there
so this is kind of cool this allows us
to be able to see um that we can
easily add and remove packages
uh so let's just go ahead and i'm going
to install express again so
install
express
oops
npm install express
all right so it's gone ahead and it's
installed express
now one of the things that often happen
is that when you're working with a
package the actual json
package so you'll receive uh this file
and you want to be able to go ahead and
install of the
sub modules that come with it so and you
can go through you can manually install
them like this or you can actually run
an install command so you can actually
install all of them at once i can just
show you what that looks like
because we're going to actually go ahead
and simulate as if we're going to
install bootstrap
which is another
popular framework
stream
and we're actually gonna go with
and then we'll save that
and what we'll see is under the packages
that bootstrap isn't listed in there we
do have
express there it is right there
so we now come over to our
new commands we can actually write the
command
npm install
and now
site typo let's try that again
let's do npm
install
okay it does help to save your file so
let's go ahead and
let's run npm install
and when you do that what we'll now
actually have is not just
express but we'll also see that
bootstrap has also been added
now i don't recommend that you use the
star symbol which will install the
latest version of bootstrap because you
obviously haven't tested your
application against that but it gives
you an idea of
what's happened here now if we want to
we can actually go in here and we can
say
on in
install
bootstrap
and it will actually remove that from
your json package so there we are that's
how you work with using npm from getting
started with a
setup for a base initialization of your
package going through to creating the
first package
being able to set up and control the
naming convention for each of the items
within the metadata that provides the
instruction for uh the package how you
can then put in dependencies such as
express and bootstrap how you can
install them and remove them and
actually use do all of this through
command line if you have any questions
please let us know
and today we're going to talk about how
you take my sequel very popular open
source database and nodejs a very
popular architecture for building up web
applications and pull the two of them
together and why you'd want to do that
so let's jump in
so first of all let's cover why you'd
want to go through this tutorial so
we're going to cover what my sequel is
we're also going to tell you how we're
going to connect with node.js and why
you'd want to do that with my sequel and
then finally we're going to do a demo
taking you through all the steps on how
you can actually do that kind of
connection
so what is my sequel well basically my
sequel is probably the world's most
popular relational database and so if
you think of relational databases that
are table driven mysql is arguably the
most popular
database out there for rdbs systems it
is by far the most popular open source
uh relational database
the entire database is written in c and
c plus plus it's been around for a
really long time um again it's open
source which is great which means that
there are no licenses or costs for
actually using my sequel and you'll find
that companies of all sizes from small
mom and pop shops all the way up to
massive enterprise global enterprises
are all using mysql so you know why
would you want to then take that next
step of connecting node.js with mysql
what fundamentally comes down to the
basics of the differences between the
two products
mysql is a database and node.js is a
architecture framework for building out
web applications now again with mysql
it's open source it's free to use you
don't have to pay anything there are no
licenses which if you compare it with
other solutions out there is a big deal
my sequel even though it is open source
it's incredibly powerful it's one of the
more mature open source programs out
there i think apache is probably
arguably more apache ui web server it's
probably more mature but my sequel is
very close behind it so it has had a
huge amount of investment this is not a
solution that's only a couple years old
we're talking about a solution that's
more than 15 years old
very very structured very powerful and
you can do a lot of really good things
with it
um you can actually then
build solutions with it and using php
java really any kind of database
even
other systems and other frameworks will
allow you to interact with mysql
and
it just allows you to work with just
huge amounts of data very very quickly
so let's go through a demo of how you'd
actually use node.js and mysql
so we're going to go ahead and we're
going to get started by putting our
environment together so let's start by
selecting node.js and downloading it so
we'll go to nodejs.org
and there you have your options for
windows mac or if you want to go for the
source code you can go ahead and
download and install that
the next is to install zap and so i'm
going to go to
zap installers for a quick search and
it's on our apache friends.org site and
here we have example windows linux and
micros 10.
and then finally we want to go ahead
and install visual studio so visual
studio is going to be our ide our
integrated development environment in
this instance we're going to use visual
student code if you don't use visual
studio code
it's a great free open source solution
for being able to build applications
i'm a big fan of it so i encourage you
to use it
and go ahead and download install that
and we have visual studio um code up and
running so go ahead and we can open up a
new folder
and let's go ahead and create a new
folder and just put a stratified desktop
here and it's just for
kicks and giggles so i'm going to type
in node mysql for our source code and
open up that folder and select that
and so we now have this folder selected
in our visual studio code editor
and what we want to do is we want to
get rid of the welcome page and we don't
really need that anymore
and
we're going to terminal window so we're
going to see the
scripts that we're writing we'll be
using tunnel quite a bit um in this so
for instance we're just going to
test that we have npm installed we do so
that's great
and we're going to go npm init and
that's actually going to set up our own
node package module and we can actually
see that the json file for that package
has been created
so we go in there we can see that all
the defaults are selected
now you'll see that index.js is the
default uh file that'll be created so
we're going to go ahead and we're going
to create our own index.js file and
we're going to add in some instructions
into that file to actually install the
correct software from the mpn package
and the first thing we want to do is
install express
which is a package that's great for
building uh lightweight web applications
not mobile applications i suppose if
you're doing a responsive design then i
guess
but in this it's really it's a web
application environment so we're going
to
put in
the requirements for that and then we're
going to also go and require that my sql
gets installed
and
[Music]
you'll see that for both of them we're
just going to use npm's default commands
for creating it and we'll go down to the
terminal window and we'll do npm install
and it's going to
install the express and my sql
environment
and as that installs you actually see on
the left hand side under uh the folder
you actually see
the files starting to be installed
so for instance we have the node modules
and underneath that will be all the
subsequent files that we need
and there we are everything is installed
all right so let's go ahead and validate
some of these commands make sure that
everything is installed so we're going
to open up zamp which allows us to go in
and
view and see that everything is stored
so we have my sequencer we have apache
installed
we can start to stop under services
with zam go ahead and do that you can do
this through total window as well but
the
ui interface is really nice so let's go
into
my
sql and interface
and you'll see that we don't have any
databases
these are all just the
standard test databases and so we have
to go ahead and create one
and so let's
get our
sql database connection created
so we're going to write
um const
db equals my sql
create connection
and we want to create connect to
the local host in this instance
and user is just going to be a root user
account
which is the standard user account that
comes from my sql there is no password
for the root user when you're running it
locally i encourage you to change that
as quickly as you can because you don't
really want to have a
password-free environment
and now we want to be able to then
connect to the mysql
environment
so do real write db dot connect
parenthesis error and we want to throw
an error message if the connection isn't
good
so if we do error
we'll throw the
error message to the log window
and
if we don't
then we'll write mysql connected
all right
and now
we want to connect that to our express
app
the next step we want to do after we
made our connection
is to go ahead and create a database so
we'll do both steps at the same one so
writing the script right now and then
we'll run the commands uh in the
terminal window so we can actually
create a database
and so we're going to go ahead and we
want to create
a database
and let's write let's sql equals
create
database
i'm going to call the database node
mysql you could call it whatever you
want um but this is just a node my sql
script
the db
query
sql
through error message
press.send
database created
so we'll throw a message saying that
database has been created let's go save
that
to demonstrate that we've connected and
we've created this let's go ahead
and
do node index.js
to run that and we'll connect it to my
sql that's great
good first step and then we'll go to
window
i will go to localhost
3000 which is
the default
connection but what you'll see is that
we've actually created the name of the
database has been changed to node by sql
so we've got an error message which we
expected and so what we're going to do
is we're actually going to go ahead
and
[Music]
we're going to say we want to listen
and if the error message if comes up to
3000
then
in the console window we want to
put a message of service started on
porsche 3000
so let's try that again
load index.js
yep and server has started with 43 000
let me refresh that
i'm still getting an error message
and what we want to see is
let's go ahead and see how database
hasn't been created
so let's go and connect to
database
database
let's go ahead and click
create db
on port 2000 all right so by doing that
we write that command and that function
and that goes and creates our database
and we'll actually see
but we have now node mysql has been
created
great first start
now we have to go in and create some
tables we have no tables in here
all right so let's go down let's go
ahead and create a table
so what you're seeing right now is that
we're using
the index.js environment within a
package on node.js to actually create
and control everything that we want to
see
in our windows so all of the work that
we're doing for creating a table for
creating the database
for initializing the core files it's all
being done through js and so here we are
going to create a new table and call it
creating it's going to be called the
employee table
and so once we run the command create
employee it's going to create a table
has the employee fields which is going
to have an
id which will be an integer that will go
into auto increment they'll have a name
field
and we'll also put in a designation
field
and
[Music]
that will have a primary key as well
keep it very simple right now
and let's just
put our db connection so that everything
connects effectively
okay so
everything goes correctly then we'll
have the message employee table created
so let's test this out
and
node.xjs
make sure that the data we have now
actually a database field that we can
connect to so we've got node my sql so
we're connecting to the correct database
obviously we get an error
and then we'll try that again
yeah okay to the database so database
has a name
and because of it noted my sequel
there's no fields in there yet
so let's go ahead and
put in create employee fields and that's
run the function that creates the new
table
and then
voila
we have a new table
and so
the next action we want to do is
actually
populate the table with a record
so
this starts becoming familiar so we're
now going to
put in a single record we'll call it
employee one for right now
and
we'll write the
the function
in an empty one and when we run that
function and he'll actually go ahead and
create the light insert the record into
my sql
and then the name will be jake smith
and the designation
will be
a chief executive officer
certainly encourage you to put your own
self name your own name into this make
yourself your own ceo because why not
and we're going to make this as an
insert record
i'm going to insert into the employee
table
i'm just using some basic sql scripting
here
and what you'll see actually with
visual studio code is that
it's actually providing a lot of prompts
to make it easier to write your code
microsoft is looking to actually add
some ai
to visual studio code to actually start
auto completing
script which will make it even easier
to write your code
all right so let's go run node index.js
we've seen everything connected and
we'll grab the
function employee one
and let's go over to our express site
let's just go and we'll insert the
command employee one
employee has been added and we will just
validate this by going back to my sql
and we'll refresh it and you'll see
we click on the employee tables we
should now have an employee in there yep
there we go jake smith
hold on jake
first record
all right so we want to be able to now
select the employee
so let's go ahead and do that
and we want to be able to easily get the
employee list
so let's use our sql command
and
do select
star which is everything
from the employee table so we're
actually playing everything from the
employee table
we're going to query the database
let's throw a message to confirm that
the query is successful
we'll put everything in the console log
results
all right let's give this a whirl
okay so let's go and run our command
or localhost 3000
but get employee
and it says employee details fetch now
we go to the console window in visual
studio yep there we go we have now all
the packet information including the id
about jake smith
okay so let's go ahead and see if we can
actually update the employee information
so as you can see now we're starting to
run into just our standard sql commands
and so we want to
be able to update the employee from a
browser
and as you can tell we're not using any
forms or any other types of records
we're just simply interacting
with between the
the browser the server and
the database
and the new name will be updated now
m
and we'll show that we're matching
against id1
all right so that's wrong
[Music]
and
[Music]
jake smith is there
now go
and select
place the employee
colon
same slash one
we've now gone ahead and updated
the
jig
and jake smith information
so let's click on
table
and we now see he says updated name i
know not very creative but
it allows you to see a change
and finally we go ahead and delete the
record as well
so it's going to be similar to
update but i'm deleting instead
and we're going to delete
the record from the employee table
name equals i t equals sorry
[Music]
and
[Music]
and then we want to be able to
show that the record has been
deleted
okay
select the link in plane
[Music]
and play deleted and we go to uh
database mean that gc
from the employee table
that there are no entries
the one-on-one record that was there has
been deleted
and so this shows you how you can very
easily control everything
from
using your connection into mysql
right from node package manager
you can create a table
you can select your records
you can then
update
any record that you selected
and finally you can delete any record
that
you want to be able to delete
here and we're going to be going through
some of the simple questions that you
would be asked during a node.js
interview uh what we're going to do is
we're actually going to break out the
section into three key areas there'll be
beginner questions there will be
intermediate questions and advanced
questions
and the expectation is as you go through
this video is that these questions could
be pushed together as you're going
through the interview kind of think of
it like this is if you answer the
beginner questions that you would get
asked at the beginning of the interview
with confidence and surety
then the client is going to then jump to
those intermediate advanced questions
quite quickly and they're looking for
people who can help them serve and solve
their problems at that more intermediate
and advanced level so let's just get
started
so the first question you're probably
going to be asked is you know you know
what is node.js you know do you know
what it's for and essentially node.js is
one of the most popular if not the most
popular uh open source cross-platform
javascript programs and it allows you to
build out web applications that run on
the server it's extremely flexible it
allows you to implement a lot of
solutions outside of just the the core
programming runtime
and allows you to build solutions
extremely quickly in an open source
mindset for devops
it is used essentially for creating
client size web applications
we'll see this later on and you may want
to talk a little bit about
using express js and how you can build
out apis
to work with node.js and connecting to
databases such as mongodb
and that is also really good for being
able to store
data intensive applications that are
asynchronous and event driven in their
model
and this is important when you're
talking about
creating applications that can scale
rapidly
so you're going to then ask be asked you
know how does nodejs work well nodejs
itself is actually built on the v8
engine and the v8 javascript engine is
the same engine that runs javascript in
your chrome web browser extremely fast
it allows for
high output and non-blocking
through your i o input outputs and is is
single threaded event loop
so you're going to be then asked you
know where can you use node.js and and
the reality is the applications for
node.js keep expanding but there are
some core applications that you can work
with node.js right now so such as web
applications distributed system and
network applications
probably referencing the web
applications is a really good starting
point because here you can actually talk
about maybe some examples that you've
done where you're building out some of
these web applications
indeed one of the things that you want
to be consistently doing and peppering
your answers with is examples of work
that you have done
now it doesn't matter if those examples
are purely experimental or
training examples that you've done the
fact that you've actually worked with
node.js and created a distributed system
or a web application
is really valuable because it shows that
the person that you're meeting with that
you have knowledge and understanding and
practical experience of applying the
theory of working with node.js with the
practice of working with node.js
so be asked about you know
essentially the io refers to the
transfer of data in and out of
a system and that's really it you know
there's a reason why google calls their
conference io it's the transfer of data
in and out of our brains at that
conference the application is same here
it's about moving data in and out of
systems through using node.js
and that every um event can be
tracked whether it's on a physical
device a network or files within a
system again it's input and output
so let's go through and you know you're
gonna be asked yo can you explain the
difference between front-end and
back-end development and this is a
question that i get asked a lot when i'm
meeting with clients um you know people
get really confused about what is the
difference between front-end and
back-end development
bottom line front-end is what gets
resolved inside of your web browser or
the app on your
mobile device back-end is what gets
resolved um essentially um what we call
the the back office or server side
applications but it's becoming more and
more synonymous for what gets run in the
cloud
so web applications um really get a lot
of the functionality of a web
application gets run in the front end
anything with css html5 uh client-side
javascript so we can get right in the
front end everything else such as
connecting to a database um gets run
behind the scenes in the back end and so
you know anything that's going to have
like graphics is going to be on the
front end uh apis are going to be run on
the back end and then just finally some
of the scripting languages are used on
on the front end so html css javascript
those are all common
core scripting languages that you would
use
you can use frameworks such as angularjs
and react.js or vue those would be a
front-end frameworks back-end frameworks
will include java php python and node.js
or some of the backend technologies
you'd also
throw in there
net as well i mean it's just the whole
you know litany of front-end and
back-end technologies and frameworks
that you can use
and this is actually a good point to
kind of explain the experience you have
outside of just working with node.js but
other technologies that you've been
working with that potentially that the
client is also using
so another question you're going to be
asked when you're looking at node.js is
you know can you tell me about npm and
so when somebody asks you what is npm
the first thing you're going to respond
is do you mean node package manager and
the reason why you want to respond like
that is that you want to qualify their
question with understanding that you
know what they're talking about but you
want them to verify that and so node
packet manager is npm
and it's responsible for packaging all
of your modules that you're working with
in node.js and we have a whole series of
videos that we've done on node.js and
every single one of them
includes references to npm
so you're going to be asking you know so
okay you tell me um what it is you know
can you go into a little bit more um
details you know can you provide two
main functionalities and so one of them
is being able to
manage online repositories of modules
and packages
so you can go to like search.nodejs.org
and you can find a packages that you can
install into your solution
such as expressjs
and it also provides a command line
utility that allows you to manage
your packages very quickly through
terminal window or command line
i use vs code a lot visual studio code
and it has a command line utility built
right into it that allows me to interact
with npm
so what are some of the modules in
node.js and so you know modules um in
node.js they're essentially like
javascript libraries so you can think of
some of the javascript libraries that
you may have used the functionality is
somewhat the same but they're designed
for node.js and to run on the server and
there are ways in which you can go ahead
and create some of those modules so for
instance
if we're creating a web server you can
actually use the require commands to be
able to require that the server be there
so the example we have on the right hand
side
shows that we really do need to have
http which is a web server and we
require that to be installed and so that
if you're running that
npm package it will actually install the
http server and then you can actually
write some code to actually then listen
on the local host port 2000 for where
you'll be running your application
and there are just you know there's a
whole bunch of modules that i come
with node.js right out of the gate and
here are some of the modules that you
have and we also referenced that just
earlier on http is a core module for
running a
web server
you have a utility function that is
useful for developers to
assess and features within your node.js
project you have a url module for any
url passing you'd be doing
and you also have a stream which allows
you to be able to stream data in and out
of your system and be able to manage how
that's being worked and then zlib which
allows you to compress and decompress
files so that you can keep
your storage of files
to a minimum
so a question you're going to be asked
is you know why is node.js being
preferred over back end technologies
such as java and php and particularly
gyro it's a very mature stable language
it's been around for more than 20 years
you know php
runs some of them the
most powerful and largest uh websites
out there such as facebook so why would
you use node.js well the first response
is kind of a gimme but it is really fast
and if you watched any of the videos
that we've done on node.js
building out solutions and developing
the solutions you'll see just how fast
it is
the second is the
really kind of the secret sauce with
node.js is the node packet manager and
no package manager allows you to install
additional functionality such as express
or [ __ ] as a database into your
solution
really quickly and there's over 50 000
bundles available for node package
manager
if you're building out a
real-time application that's data
intensive and you need to have apis
quickly developed then node.js is
another great it's really the great
solution for you it allows you to build
out these solutions really quickly
and there is a easy synchronization
between the server and the client
due to the code base
and then finally because the structure
of node.js is javascript if you are
making the pivot from being a front-end
web developer to node.js it's just going
to make it a lot easier for you to pick
up
node.js because you have that common
language of javascript
and on top of that javascript is the
world's most popular
scripting language
so let's talk about some of the
differences between angular and node.js
and so the reason why this question may
come up is the person interviewing you
is seeing whether or not you do know the
difference between a front-end
framework and a back-end framework and
this is one of those questions where you
can go well
there are differences but the
differences are because they complement
each other
so angular is a front-end development
framework whereas node.js is a
server-side in framework other
differences though between the actual
frameworks themselves is that angular is
written in typescript which is a
modification of javascript nodejs is
written in c and c plus plus
angular is used for building out single
page
client-side web applications and so
that's a key word there is client-side
whereas node.js is about building out
fast and scalable server-side network
applications and so
again the two complement each other
uh angular splits web applications into
the mvc and model view control
components whereas node.js generates a
lot of database grades it does more than
that as well but you can think of
node.js as that glue to your database
so let's talk a little bit about when
you're connecting to a database with
node.js and so um you're going to
probably be asking what is
the most popular database used with
node.js and there are a couple um
mongodb is largely the most popular
nosql cross-platform database
mysql is also very popular and that's a
more traditional relational database
um you would go with mongodb
for really more modern solutions when
you're looking at creating an
application that's going to really scale
into just managing masses and masses
of data that has to be
created read updated and deleted very
very quickly
for
some of the other popular libraries that
you use for node.js express.js is a very
popular one i really like working with
express.js allows me to build out web
applications really quickly
more importantly it allows me to build
out apis very quickly and which you know
apis are essentially web applications
themselves but being able to do that
very quickly with a framework like
express.js is very useful
mongoose is an application that makes
connecting to a [ __ ] database really
easy so
here is an example of express.js which
is a in itself really a flexible budge a
solution that you can do lots with and
mongoose which is a more
focused solution um which allows
you know to you make it easier to
connect to your databases
so you know what are the pros and cons
of working with node.js there's lots of
ways we explained this earlier on that
you can actually build out
applications that run on the cloud why
would you you know what's are the pros
and cons so a pro is that uh node.js is
extremely fast a processing an event
based model uh it really is fast a con
is if you have something that is a very
heavy computational task it's not so
good at that
now i will caveat that this is that
node.js is getting better all the time
and so
you might have to be provide an example
of what a very heavy computational task
is and that may be
calculating
a risk on an insurance application
against
many many variables that may be
something that is seen as
computationally very heavy but what you
can do in that example is you can
offload
the task to another solution that's
designed for it and use apis to pass the
data back and forth
pro
javascript is used for building out your
applications with
node.js great lots of people know
javascript
a
restriction and again this is evolving
as javascript itself evolves is that
when you do a call back you may end up
doing lots of nested call backs um if
you're doing something that's very
complicated again another way around the
con and so this is one of the things
that i always look for is if you have a
blocker or a barrier
how do you get around that barrier and
so for instance when you're talking to
your recruiter
you can say look the reason why i use
node.js is that it's fast it's event
based driven i can use javascript there
are some challenges and but what i do to
get around those challenges are and
that's where you can say that you know
you may run the complex script off and
you may write that in net or java or php
and then use an api to do the response
back into node.js so you get the
benefits of both worlds but minimize the
investment in having to manage a complex
environment such as java versus a
relatively simple environment with
node.js
the node package manager makes it
extremely easy to access just an awful
lot of functionality with over 50 000
packages there's a package for that
so from being able to have a
tool that creates unique identifiers
that you might need to have for
generating content that gets posted into
a database through to being able to
connect to databases through you know to
running so many different solutions and
the npm package manager with this access
to so many different packages makes it
great
for
getting access to all that content now a
con is working with relational databases
with node.js isn't as easy as a nosql
database now you can do it and there are
ways around that and what i would do
when this question comes up is always
kind of pivot to say hey this is how you
can actually then
get around building out that application
pro for node.js designed for streaming
huge amounts of data in and out a con is
that node.js is singles threaded and so
it can be cpu intensive
but again there are ways around that and
a good way around that is scaling your
solution in elastic environments such as
the cloud
so what is the command used to import an
external library and so to import an
external library the command is the
required command and so an example we
have here is uh you can start a variable
and the variable's going to be for http
and you're going to then require the
http service
that means that the application itself
won't run unless the external library
the http library is installed
okay so those were our introductory
questions for node.js let's kind of
pivot and take a look at the
intermediate questions that you would be
asked
so what does event driven programming
mean so event driven programming means
that if something happens something else
will happen in response so for instance
if you click a mouse that mouse click is
an event that means something has to
respond to that event uh just think of
it as cause and effect it's just the
basic motion of physics so that's what
event driven programming means
you also look at it as a callback
function
so that when an element is executed
something will happen in response
so what is an event loop in node.js
so an event loop in node.js is when you
do an asynchronous call and
what that essentially means is that
you're sending out
data and then a non-blocking input
output
from node.js is pulling data back in
what is an event emitter in node.js so
an event emitter has really two areas of
focus one is that it manages
the classes that hold all the objects
within your event and we have an example
of this on the right hand side
and then whenever an event actually is
thrown uh the functions are then called
on that event synchronously uh so for
instance we have in our example on the
right hand side we create an event and
then we have the functions and that
executed in a series from
that event
so let's talk about the api functions in
node.js so there's two types
one is an asynchronous non-blocking
function and the second is a synchronous
blocking function and the difference
between the two of them is asynchronous
is that there is no structure to the
order
for how the
api is resolved synchronous means that
when the feedback from the api is
received you have to execute
the response in a series for how the
response is sent to you
so what is a package.json file so the
package json file is at the heart of our
node.js
package where we actually will
initialize a solution a folder to be a
node.js
package
you'll find that the package itself
holds all of the metadata that's
particular to the project you're working
on such as project name version
requirements it is you have to have
installed in the root of the directory
for the project and
again look at any of the videos that we
have on node.js we do have
demonstrations within those videos that
actually then go through and break out
how to create that root package and
you'll see how you can actually then go
ahead and update the instructions or the
metadata within the package
so here we have an example of what that
metadata looks like so again this kind
of continues that question of what is a
package.json file and you may be asked
you know what is the metadata and why is
it important and the metadata is a
basic
json collection of pairing of
a key details such as name version
description and then the custom version
that you put so for instance under name
you could create a name for your project
there can't be any spaces
what is the version and the description
and what is the main or starting path
for the solution typically that would be
index.js but it could be anything.js but
index.js is typical simply because
index.html is the starting point for a
typical web application
so how would you use a url module in
node.js
so with the url module what it allows
you to do is really two things one is
that it provides the resolution and
passing of a url
for utilities in your application
and then it allows you to
extend your module with built-in
solutions and split up the web address
into a readable format
so in this example
we have the url and
the response it would give
for that url which would then be a year
and month
and it'd be in a readable format so it
would read out as
2020 and then the month
so what is express.js and you've heard
me mention this a couple of times in the
video we actually have a separate video
on express.js and express.js is a web
application framework that allows you to
build out web solutions
for both mobile and traditional desktop
right inside of node.js so it's very
easy to use
um being able to install web.js is as
simple as requiring express to be
installed in the example that we have
here on the screen it's a full solution
of showing how to actually build out a
solution with web.js
so in this example uh you start off the
first two lines require express to be
installed and the store comes from node
packet manager then we have a simple
application that will then send to the
browser window
a hello world message confirming that
express is up and running and then the
third block of content starting with
virus server actually will define the
port
where your application is going to run
so in this instance
the port is going to run on localhost
and the
port will be port 8081
and so you can actually go to localhost
colon8081 and when you do that that will
trigger the application that will
forward up the message hello world and
it's all coming from express.js
so what are streams in node.js so
streams are objects that allow you to
read and write data continuously back
and forth within your application and
there's really four different types of
streams there's readable writable duplex
and transform
the readable stream through which data
can be read
the writable streams that you can
actually write to
a duplex is a stream where is both
readable and writeable
and
transform our streams that can be
manipulate the data
while it is being read or written
so how do you update and delete a
dependency so say for instance we want
to install uh something like express so
if you wanted to install express what
you would do is you would just write
them inside of your project you want to
go to terminal window and write in the
command mpm install express
if you want to update the
dependencies within your node package
manager to update all of them all you
have to do is
write the command npm update all
dependencies
and then if you want to explicitly
uninstall a dependency such as
express.js
that's using the uninstall command and
so that would again be going to terminal
window and you would type npm uninstall
express
and again it's really easy to create a
simple server in node.js that will run a
simple command
the http service is actually built into
node.js you don't need to use expressjs
i typically use express.js when i want
to do a web server because typically
what i find is that i will want to go
and do something more complicated but if
you want to do something that
illustrates just the core functionality
uh within node.js you can actually just
require the core http service that
actually comes as part of node.js and
then you can actually then go ahead and
tell it to create a service and then to
write in plain text a command
or text string such as in this case
it'll be hello world and that would pop
out and then the final line is to then
uh listen that if you go to a web
browser that's on port
127.0.01 or localhost
and go to port colon 8080 once you
actually go to that that will trigger
this application and you'll get the text
hello world pop up on your screen
so explain synchronous and non-blocking
apis in node.js
so all the apis
in node.js are asynchronous which means
that they are non-blocking which means
you can run them continuously
and scale around that which is just
fantastic it's one of the reasons why
node.js can scale so fast and the eighth
means that the apis can return data send
data after it's been called and really
increase the efficiency of events as
they are triggered within node.js
so how do you implement async and
node.js and so the example that we have
on the left hand side allows us to
trigger async and it's using the async
function and as you can see in this
example
it's actually something that can be done
very quickly in this example we're
actually
making a command to logo host and app
that's running on port 3000 and then
depending on what we get if there's an
error message and then we'll have error
message go to the console log which is
the terminal window and if
we get a response to an application
then we'll actually get a positive
response which would be fetched response
so
again very quickly and easy that you use
the async function
to be able to build out and you to get
your
asynchronous code
so what is the purpose of module exports
so
a module export is a way to encapsulate
your the entire code for a solution in a
single package in a single file and then
you can then share that with other
developers so you're all working from
the same environment
so what is a callback function in
node.js a callback function is
essentially that once you run and you've
triggered an event and the response has
been given
you want to be able to then have a
callback to validate that the task is
complete
all right let's move on to the final set
of questions which is advanced node.js
questions
so what is repple in node.js so repl
stands for read eval print and loop and
this is a reference to the
unix and linux background that node.js
has
so raffle will form the following tasks
the read will be actually
passing the javascript you'll read that
and store it in memory eval
takes and evaluates the data structure
print will then print the results often
on the console window or onto a web page
and then loop um loops the above command
until the user presses control c twice
what is the control flow function so the
control flow function is a piece of code
that runs between several of the
asynchronous functions
and that's it it actually controls how
those functions execute
so how control flow controls the
function calls and it does it through
four ways one is it controls the order
of execution it collects the data it
limits the concurrency and then it also
calls the next step in a program again
this is a management tool for how your
functions are called within node.js
so what is the difference between fork
and spawn methods in node.js
so the essential difference between the
two of them is that if you use the fork
method it will actually trigger and
create a new instance of the v8 engine
the engine running node.js
and will then run the application in
that new instance
with spawn
it's somewhat similar it doesn't
actually generate a new v8 instance so
it's actually creating a new process but
it's within the same v8 instance as the
previous application that it was spawned
from
explain to me what is the use of buffer
class in node.js
so with the buffer class what you're
looking at doing is you're actually
controlling the raw data of a set of
arrays and integers and the memory
allocation outside of the v8 heap buffer
class is used because pure javascript is
not compatible with binary data
what is piping in node.js
so
piping is the ability to connect the
output of one stream to another stream
that could be a data stream it could be
any stream that you're working with
but it does normally get used to pass
data from one stream to another
so what are some of the flags used in
the rewrite operation files
so r dash is used for read w's for
opening a file for writing
a dash is opening a file for appending
so the collection that you have here you
don't have to really memorize all of
them but to have a few of them in the
back of your mind is always a good
reference point
so how would you open a file using
node.js
so
the syntax you would use would be
the
fs.open and that would then open up a
file
explain to me what callback hell is uh
so callback hell also known as the
pyramid of doom is when you have too
many
nested unreadable and unmanageable
callbacks intensively cycle within each
other and they're constantly reading to
each other and they're not able to
resolve the solution
and
this is a you know it's a big problem
and this is what why it's called
callback hell because you're not able to
finalize the the app you're working on
what is a reactive pattern in node.js
and so a reactor pattern is a concept of
non-blocking i o operations
can you explain to me the test pyramid
for node.js so the test pyramid and this
is standard for testing uh for all
devops is really split into three key
areas you have unit tests integration
tests and then end-to-end or e2e tests
the unit tests are tests that you
actually do in your raw code that you're
working on and the goal there is to be
able to validate that the code you're
writing is consistently working
integration allows you to um have tests
that integrate your raw code that you're
working with in your application with
other areas of an application and then
end to end is the whole system the whole
interface as it were
for your solution
describe the exit codes of node.js
so annexa code is a specific code that
identifies the end of a specific process
and examples of exit codes are
unused uncaught fatal exception
fatal error
internal javascript evaluation area
these are all good examples of exit
codes
so what is
a middleware can you explain the concept
of middleware in nodejs
so
with middleware it is the ability to be
able to connect to a system and get data
from it
that's outside of node.js so
this may be executing a type of code or
updating and modifying a request in
response to a specific type of object
finishing the request response cycle
can you explain to me what are the types
of http requests that you may use when
working with node.js
there are actually quite a lot but four
of them that you might use would be get
post head and delete
and these are if you've done any uh web
application before particularly worked
with forms inside of a web application
you're probably very familiar with
certainly with get and post
again it's the request to retrieve data
post is generally used for changing
stating and data
head is similar to get but also ask for
a response if there's no body content so
if you're using if you're developing an
api this would be a good one to use and
delete is used to delete the
predetermined source
so how would you connect to mongodb
database and with node.js and you use
that using the [ __ ] client and the
example we have on the left hand side
and illustrates that
what is the use of node underscore emv
and so this node underscore emv is an
environment variable that stands for
node environment in express server so
the example we have on the right hand
side allows you to illustrate how you
would do that for say a production
environment
so what are some of the various timing
features in node.js so
the timing functions that you could use
here set timeout and then clear timeout
and you to schedule code execution that
you'd have inside of your application
you also have set interval clear
interval to execute a block of code up
multiple times in your application
set intermediate and clear intermediate
to
execute code and that is at the end of
your application
i hope this video was useful for you if
yes do like and share this video to the
maximum until then happy learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you